it's great to welcome back to the
program Anthony Fantan oh the Internet's
busiest music nerd and editor-in-chief
of the needle drop and I guess Anthony
like sort of a little bit to my surprise
more and more involved in the political
space I don't I mean not surprised I
like I know you so I know you are a
political guy but you know that
sometimes people who aren't working
directly in politics want to stay away
from it for business reasons so to speak
yeah I I think that I found not too long
ago the the more that I don't know I
found myself ranting about it on social
media the more it wasn't so much a big
deal I mean of course still to this day
I do catch a lot of responses that are
like just stick to music but I found
like a a one about a one to one
correlation between people who say that
and people who actually disagree with
what I'm saying so it's it's interesting
to find that the people who just don't
want me to talk about politics are the
ones who just don't want to hear the
point of view that I'm espousing as
opposed to your the music guy you
shouldn't be talking about this or that
or the other thing I feel like on this
issue I am basically like a just
libertarian in the sense that I am
completely fine with anyone using
whatever platform they've built for
themselves to talk about whatever they
want and and the free market of ideas
will dictate whether there are
repercussions to that speech like if you
have a basketball player who says I'm
gonna use my celebrity to at every
opportunity courtside interview off you
know locker room interview whatever to
talk about politics that's great and if
I'm so turned off by their politics that
I say I'm not gonna go and see the team
play in person or whatever that's
actually like a free-market reaction and
I would not whether it's a celebrity or
someone like you who's built their
platform initially on music I mean I
think it's great and people can decide
how they want to deal with someone's
political views period
yeah and specifically when it comes to
politics I feel like every person has a
responsibility to be engaged in the
political process and what's going on
with how our country is being run no
matter what President is in power around
that
and yeah I mean I suppose I'm
libertarian about it as you just said I
mean anybody can use their platform to
talk about any issue that they're
passionate about sure absolutely
but like I said in in in my experience
and also as you've just said there with
the Sports example it seems like
consistently there is this narrative
coming from the right of just stay in
your lane shut up and dribble you know
don't be talking about this that or the
other thing and I don't know for me
personally and I understand
well why other people would be attracted
to it it's it's a difficult subject to
stay away from not only because there
are a lot of horrible things going on
that are worth talking about but on top
of that our politicians usually aren't
addressing these issues as boldly as
they should not only through legislation
but through engagement with the
electorate through speeches social media
PR events that sort of thing and I think
that leaves open a huge vacuum in which
people are dying for some kind of
acknowledgment or validation from their
officials from their higher-ups from
their leaders of this is not normal
right
there's something wrong with this this
is kind of crazy things could be
different things could be better and
sure there are politicians this newer
wave of them coming out now like AOC and
you know who they refer to as the squad
and of course Bernie has been at it for
a long time and I think that voices like
Elizabeth Warren has been speaking a lot
of these speaking on a lot of these
issues for a long time too but Jen these
people still make up a very small
fraction of the larger base of senators
and congressmen and public officials
that we have elected to government and
are working on our behalf allegedly
every single day so what do you make
right now of the intersection that
exists to the extent that it exists
between culture and I include music and
gaming and movies and all of these
things in there and the political world
because at the sort of highest level
like when you think of Trump it's like
okay the guy is known for being a
reality host more than anything else to
to people around the world and in the
United States at least before being
the notable interactions he's had with
the sort of music and cultural world
recently we had this ASAP rocky thing in
Sweden he famously had Kim Kardashian
convince him about you know the the
release of someone from prison although
at a more systemic level he's been you
know pretty pretty milquetoast as far as
what he's done with with one sort of
exception in one bill that he passed
what is your interpretation of the
interplay and the overlap that right now
exists between the space you primarily
occupy and the presidency in the
political world god it's it's a weird
mix of everything I mean as far as music
goes I grew up listening to music that
you know has a lot of political
overtones to it I mean I enjoy a lot of
pop music as well but some of my
favorite artists growing up or bands
like Rage Against the Machine you know
whose lyrics I'd go pretty deeply into
and you know even as a kid got this
sense of unfairness and corruption and
corporate power influencing our
government in a negative way but I would
say that we're not getting as many
messages from mainstream music these
days as we could along those lines or
just political messages in general
because of how volatile music careers
and the music industry tends to be these
days through streaming through the sheer
saturation of artists that are in the
limelight at any given time through the
risk that any artist is putting
themselves at by coming out with a song
that has a political message on it that
might not necessarily hit or resonate
with an audience I mean it does happen
every once in a while I'm sure that
you've heard that childish gambino song
this is America and of course Glover has
been doing quite a bit lately too and
interject a little more politics and and
messaging in his songs that he's been
dropping as of late but still it's it's
it's rare that you're catching music in
the mainstream that has any kind of
political overtone to it and I would say
it's it's even harder to come across
these days than it was when I was much
younger especially when hip-hop used to
be a lot more politically charged and
and speak to I guess a class and race
economic struggles of you know whatever
places those artists were coming from
around that time those narratives are
genuinely a risk in the sense so okay I
think back to the Dixie Chicks in
whenever it was that I don't even
believe and I'm sure you'll correct me I
don't recall that the content of their
album was political but they said by the
way we're against the Iraq war and we
don't like George Bush and this is you
know here's the thing it's not it's not
a risk in that sense right away their
career essentially got halted by your
audience turning against them at that
point it's more of a risk of people
tuning out you know there's no section
of the hip-hop audience honestly that is
going to attack their favorite artists
if they come out with some anti Trump
song but because of how a lot of people
go to music merely for entertainment and
how social media has I think offloaded
and become a bit of a pressure release
valve for a lot of people's political
and social opinions when people are
listening to their new artists their new
favorite artists latest record they just
want to hear something that they could
vibe to they want to hear something
that's going to allow them to escape
from all the horrible things that
they're dealing with day to day being
faced with harsh realities and bold
political opinions isn't always
something most people are looking to
hear your general audience member when
they want to basically just put on
something that they can have a good time
to unfortunately I wish it was different
I wish it was flipped but I think the
risk that artists are taking is that
their fans could tune out and just go
listen to something else that is going
to fit into the mood that they're trying
to feed by putting on a record that they
you know just want to give themselves a
bit of background music - just relax - I
guess there does seem to be some sort of
unique interest from a lot of people
just in the general public and knowing
the political views of people that they
follow I think that if I remember the
story right Garth Brooks had been
invited to perform at Trump's
inauguration and didn't but then when he
was asked about it he said
wasn't a political statement it was a
scheduling conflict which was then
reinterpreted as oh he's saying he
gladly would have done it and he is a
trump as ultimately I don't know what
Garth Brooks politics are but it was an
example of that sort of it seemed like
trying to be decidedly non-committal
about listen I just couldn't be there
for a scheduling reason and it seemed
very calculated in that sense this this
idea in this narrative I think is is
sort of as old as time at this point it
is not a recent Trump related phenomenon
I mean in Indy music most likely the
biggest case of this is uh is Morrissey
of the Smiths who for decades and
decades and decades fans have agonized
about just how problematic or offensive
or ridiculous or out of pocket his views
or his opinions are an interview after
interview after interview and it just
doesn't seem to get any better in fact I
would say it seems to get even worse
like with the passage of time
however yeah I think I think your
average fan who is really emotionally
invested in their favorite music in
their favorite artists they create such
a deep personal connection with what
that person is making that they ascribe
all sorts of very positive and very very
I would say like self paralleled
opinions of how that person is what they
think how they must be and then when
they catch an interview or they meet
them in person and they're shocked to
find out that they're not a nice person
or they hold some heinous points of view
it can be kind of earth-shattering and
what I would recommend to people
generally is that even if you enjoy some
album like it's it's changed your life
or something like that don't allow that
to lead you to believe that that means
the people who made that record are
great people or that they hold all the
same opinions that you do I mean in most
cases that's probably not going to hold
up so years ago when you were on you and
I talked about how we're music artists
get their money has really changed over
time that the idea of like the super
lucrative record deal has kind of been
replaced by streaming and using
to sell concert tickets and that it's
really just sort of a new business model
so I'm curious you are aware of the
issues that political youtubers and
independent media have been having with
monetization on YouTube and the amount
of power that advertisers ultimately
sort of have over whether if I talk
about Jeffrey Epstein am I making money
or am I not making money on that because
of the their whims rather than what is
serving the public interest do you see
any parallels between the ways in which
large corporations be it those that
determine how many fractions of a penny
you get per stream or how many fractions
of a penny I get per pre-roll ad are
increasingly in control of culture
politics news the the sort of water
cooler topics that are that are out
there I can't say that there's any from
what I've heard them from what I've read
I don't know if there's as much concern
around the industry as far as higher-ups
talking to artists who they've signed to
their label in terms of these issues
should not be addressed in your music
and in that sort of thing
I think instantaneously what matters
most is whether or not the streams are
there whether or not the audience
engagement is there if some artist comes
on a record and says something
absolutely radical or even does a song
about the whole Jeffrey Epstein thing if
that track ends up platinum tomorrow the
labels will not care you know though
okay that tracks platinum that is you
know in fact because they see that
pattern they will try to find ways to
recreate that same sensation because the
labels are in a position where they're
just constantly chasing after and for a
long plane of trends and because there
aren't advertisers buying into the music
that is uh you know being placed on to
Apple music or Spotify and of course
these artists do you know ad deals but
this is a different discussion because
there aren't advertisers in the mix in
that equation we don't necessarily have
to be all that concerned about songs or
various topics being user friendly I
mean I mean being being advertiser
friendly is
the word that I'm looking for so there's
there's not really as much concern on
that end I guess but I will say in
extension of our last conversation now
that labels have mostly figured out the
equation when it comes to really making
money off this whole streaming thing
they are now pulling in billion dollar
profits at this point collectively as
far as the major labels go and we are
starting to see some of those big
multi-million dollar deals come back
with artists like logic who I know has
made you know at least one multi-million
dollar deal for his latest batch of
records Rockhampton as well I'm sure
it's continuing with continuing with
other artists too but yeah we actually
are starting to see some of those deals
come back and we're starting to see them
publicized here and they're a little bit
more - when you look at the future of
the music industry in the context of
corporate control versus independence
what do you see as sort of for someone
who maybe doesn't follow the industry as
closely as you do what are the sort of
like big discussions or tipping points
that could in the next couple of years
push the industry in one way or in a
completely different direction I think
for a while when the internet started to
really begin to inch into the profits
and the traffic and the attention that
the music industry was able to generate
interest in through old mediums like
magazines and radio and so on and so
forth as soon as the internet started
inching in on that I think we saw a bit
of a very short golden ish era of
independence in terms of new writers
online and blogs in every which
direction that we're covering a variety
of different artists and musical trends
that that were just of the interest of
the person writing you know there wasn't
anyone pushing them to do that or
anything like that and and sure you know
that system did have its issues and I
and I do think it was a little limited
in its coverage of a lot of different
genres which is why that blog boom that
I'm referring to that happened in the
2000s is like really
no we're at this point but um I think
now that major labels and the
traditional music media industry what's
left of it have figured out the internet
for the most part we're starting to
slide back into that direction where
there is some gatekeeping and there is
more corporate control and there is more
of a top-down influence on what people
are listening to overall I would say
it's still way better than what we had a
majority of in the 2000s but still these
days when it comes to getting play
getting attention getting an audience
for your song or for your record what
was once I don't know a positive review
and spin or like in the source or
something like that has become top
placement in a Spotify playlist you know
that sort of become the new thing these
curators that run and work on these
streaming platforms are essentially kind
of guiding the tastes of of your average
music listener who is hopping on Spotify
who's hopping on Apple music and is just
looking for something that they could
put on without having to think too much
of it something they just play in the
background will provide a little bit of
variety without veering too much outside
of the norm to the point where it's
attention-grabbing or I guess interrupts
whatever they have going on primarily in
the foreground while the music just
plays in the background I've referred to
this on a few occasions is the playlist
off' occasion of music itself where you
hear a lot of weird genre clashes and
combinations that I don't think you
would have caught previous previously on
albums years and years ago where you
hear predominantly on a lot of major
records a lot of tracks whose production
and singing and instrumentation are very
pillowy not so much so that they become
ambient but just enough to where it's
catchy it's sweet it sort of falls into
the background its playlists that are
able to combine as many songs in this
style that end up getting the most play
and the most runtime and the most
attention because there's nothing
mentally that interrupts the listener
and the listening experience of that
playlist and it sort of drives this
demand for artists to try to
to meet those aesthetics in their own
music so they could end up on one of
these playlists or at least appeal to
people on that level so they capture
people sort of in that same mindset when
a listener is checking out their new
album fascinating changes that will no
doubt continue Anthony Fantana not only
the Internet's busiest music nerd but
also really a connoisseur of independent
progressive media I think I would say
people may not know that you are you
really are you have your finger on the
pulse of what's happening in an
independent progressive media I watched
too much of it honestly I've been a news
junkie for a long time and and I went to
college and studied you know not just
journalism and not just broadcast media
but political science itself I thought
out of college I would go into political
reporting but I just ended up kind of
sticking with music but it's you know
politics and everything going on in that
spheres something I've kept up with for
a very long time and have been active in
since teenager at some level or another
and yeah I've been watching your show
for a long long time I can't remember
the last like the first time we emailed
was probably like the weight like
earlier in the first leg of this decade
I can't remember yeah yeah first contact
that we had but yeah I've been on your
show I think yours and Kyle's shows are
probably two of the earliest that I
caught on YouTube as far as like
political content on the platform and
still watching today appreciate it so
much
Anthony Fanta no Internet's busiest
music nerd and editor-in-chief of the
needle drop check him out on YouTube
where he has way more subscribers than I
do
Anthony always a pleasure to talk to you
not for a long day long